another day another Kanye West
controversy this time over shirts
sporting the phrase quote White lives
matter Paris is the Church of passion on
Monday the rapper surprised fans at
yeezy's Paris week Fashion Show by
posing it up in the design with
polarizing conservative commentator
Candice Owens I believe our government
is interested in liberating ukrainians
like I believe that the black lives
matter riots were about liberating black
Americans which is to say not at all the
political pundit posted these photos on
Twitter No captions on the pics it's
worth noting the Anti-Defamation League
condemns the saying as a quote white
supremacist phrase born out of a quote
racist response to the black lives
matter movement
[Applause]
et's reached out to Kanye's reps about
the controversial fashion statement so
far he's provided no explanation even
though he gave interviews about his new
collection backstage it looked like
there's just everything pulled on over
the head yeah that was the idea there
was no zippers if you're the smartest
person in the room you're in the wrong
room the shocking shirts struck a nerve
online especially since it's quite the
pivot from who the rapper used to be
George Bush doesn't care about black
people
among the backlash journalist Jamil Hill
who says quote so many folks are trying
to excuse Kanye wearing a white lives
matter t-shirt as just a troll move or
marketing but it's a dangerously dumb
message to send for someone with his
massive platform Jaden Smith who says he
left the show as soon as the shirts
popped up on the runway sends a simple
message simply tweeting quote black
lives matter anyone with a position of
powered entertainment should be held
accountable for racism activist Mark
Lamont Hill calls Kanye's decision quote
disgusting dangerous and irresponsible
some of y'all will rushed to defend him
you should ask yourselves why while van
Lathan host of The Higher Learning
podcast argues quote the notion that it
always has to be about white people in
America is incredibly frustrating
emotionally draining and the whole
problem but here's Kanye apparently
centering that notion